the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
all right I want to thank you all for
coming to the third lecture of the
signal processing on databases class we
will go just to remind folks all the
material is available in the
distribution of the software which you
all have in your L R it accounts here
we're gonna go to lecture two courses
course which brings together signal
processing which is based on detection
theory which is based on linear algebra
with with databases which are based on
strings and searching and sort of really
bringing those two concepts together in
this this course so that we can use the
the mathematics that we know from
detection theory and apply it into new
new domains I'm glad to see we have a
full house again so so far I've failed
and scaring off people so let's see if
we can do a better job I think this
course will do a much this particular
lecture should do a very good job of
that the we're gonna be getting into a
little bit some more of the the
mathematics that underpins the
associative array construct that is in
the D form technology that we're using
in the class and gets into some group
Theory concepts that may might be a long
time since then you've had any that or
even recall what that is it's actually
not that complicated personally this is
my favorite lecture in terms of it
really gets into sort of the the deeper
underlying elements I would fully expect
it to make your head hurt a little bit
we're gonna do sort of a fairly rapid
blast through the mathematics here now
and and you won't really have to know
this really to effectively use it
although it's good to know that it
exists
and and that there and that there might
be pieces of it that you want to drive
into deeper and so you know the really
the title of this talk is called
spreadsheets big tables in the algebra
of associative arrays
we've lectured on that topic in the past
and so with that we will get right into
it so here's the outline for the lecture
and I should say you know there's a
balance between the lecture and then
we'll have some examples this particular
lecture will be a little bit more heavy
on the lecture side and the example
piece is a little bit bit shorter and so
so a little bit more lecture a little
less example on this particular class so
we're gonna talk about kind of a
mathematical concept for what our
spreadsheets and in the introduction
here talk about what our theoretical
goals are and then really what
associative arrays are getting into the
mathematical definitions what is the
group theory and then sort of leading
into the sort of traditional linear
algebra vector spaces and other types of
things just sort of getting you a sense
of so this really is what connects those
two things at the deeper mathematical
level so what are spreadsheets in big
tables so spreadsheets particularly
obviously Microsoft Excel tends to
dominate the spreadsheet world are
arguably the most commonly used analytic
structure on earth probably a hundred
million people if not a larger number
use a spreadsheet every single day you
know perhaps a good fraction of the
planet NOW has used a spreadsheet at
some point the other big tables which
are these large triple store databases
that we have discussed in Prior lectures
are really what is used to store mostly
analyze data on earth so Google Amazon
they all have these giant triple store
databases which can be looked at the
thought about is gigantic gigantic
spreadsheet
really rows and columns and values and
stuff and and the the power is that they
really can simultaneously store diverse
data you know you can hold in the same
data structure strings and dates and
integers and reels and all different
types of data and you can treat them
very differently you can treat them as
we've shown here this is just one
spreadsheet we can treat it as a matrix
we can treat it as you know functions
hash tables you know little mini
databases all in the same spreadsheet we
can kind of hold this information so
it's a very powerful concept the
spreadsheet yet we lack any formal
mathematical basis for this in fact I
looked up in the American mathematical
Association and the Siam databases the
word spreadsheet okay and it did not
appear in a single title or an abstract
other than say you know maybe with
referred to some software but the this
this core thing that we use every day
every single time we do a Google search
we're using it every single time we do a
spreadsheet we're using it has no formal
mathematical structure and so that seems
like a little bit of a problem right
that we maybe we should have some formal
mathematical structure and so this
mathematical thing called an associative
array actually gives us a mathematical
structure that really encompasses this
in a fairly nice way I'm sure there's
cases that it doesn't but the core of
what it is really really works so I
think that's a powerful concept so what
is our overall goal here so we want to
create a formal basis for working with
these types of data structures in a more
mathematically rigorous way this allows
us to create better algorithms because
we can now apply the traditional tools
of linear algebra and detection theory
to these types of data it saves time in
terms of generally if you have the
mathematical background you can
implement things using a lot less code
which usually means a lot less lines and
often you can build on top of existing
optimized libraries which give you
better performance and we threw out a
number of 50x less effort for those with
the required training they can they can
do they can they can do this and that is
something that we've observes a number
of occasions and you know it's it's good
for managers too I've tried to have
recruit group leaders at Lincoln
Laboratory so you really should use d4m
I could connect it to sa P no problem
you'll really you know and get them
feeling like they're actually doing
programming again you know haven't had
too many takers of that yet so hopefully
we can you know maybe as you folks start
using it they'll see using it binding to
the various enterprise databases at the
laboratory is very easy to do and using
D forum to analyze it's fairly easy to
do so so you know I actually use it now
instead of like if I'm going to use
Excel I'll often just be like now I'll
just write a CSV file and just use D for
M for manipulating basic Excel types of
operations just because it feels a lot
more natural to me and so that that's
you know I certainly have done that so
we're gonna get into this associative
array concept which we discussed in some
of the earlier lectures we're going to
get into more deeply now but but the the
real benefit of the associative array
concept is that naturally pulls together
four different ways of thinking about
your data into one structure and you can
apply the reasoning from any of these
four ways of thinking sort of
interchangeably now so we can think
about data as as associative arrays as
arrays that are indexed by by by words
this is similar to what therel does and
hashes of hashes or
we can have you know ro keys that are
words and column keys that are words and
then values that are words or numbers
this concept is one-to-one with our
triple store bait databases so we can go
naturally from triples to this and
inserting data into a database and get
you know you know if our data is an
associative array we can very quickly
say please insert it into a database and
if we do a query it can return an
associative write to us very nicely this
this obviously connects to graphs so if
we want to store relationships and grass
between vertices in any edit ease so we
have Alice Bob sighted which is dual to
the linear algebraic matrix formulation
of graphs you know Allison row Alice
column column Bob you know they're edged
associated between them so we have these
four very powerful ways of looking at
our data and they're out now all sort of
brought together as one concept so I
kind of argued it's sort of a one of the
best deals in math you'll get you know
if you know one you get the other three
for free right and that's that's really
what the whole point of math is right is
if you give me a whole bunch of
information I can calculate something
else that you didn't know and typically
in signal processing that deal is more
like well if you give me 50 pieces of
information I can give you the fifty
first here if you give me one you know I
can give you three so it's a really good
bargain as a little anecdote I was
working with my daughter
teaching her the parallel geometry lines
problem you know parallel lines
I was tuner this is the best deal in
math right because you know one angle
and you get the other seven free so
we're not quite as good as that that's
probably the best deal in math going and
that's why they teach it so much is if
you know one angle you get the other
seven for free here we you know one of
these concepts you essentially get the
other other for free so it's a very
powerful concept and and it's really
kind of at the core of the benefit of
this technology
as much as possible we try and make it
that any operation on an associative
array returns another associative array
so this gives you sort of the
mathematical concept of closure linear
algebra works because the vast majority
of operations on a on a matrix return
another matrix and so you can compose
these together mathematically and create
sequences of operation which are
conceptually easy to think about so
because of that we can create operations
like adding associated associated rays
subtracting associative arrays anning
them mooring them multiplying them
together and the result of every one of
these operations will be another
associative array and so that's a very
powerful powerful concept and likewise
we can do very easy query operations we
if we want to get rows Alice and Bob row
Alice rows beginning with al rows Alice
to Bob the first two rows everything
equal to 47 and every single one of
these will return another associative
array so so again this compositional
concept is very very important it's not
to say we don't use the triples
formulation too and we have routines
that very quickly bounce you back and
forth between them because there are
times just like no I want to view this
as a set of of triples and I want to do
operations that way as well so we
support them both but but this this is
really sort of the core composable
aspect in fact most people initially
develop their codes and this in this
formalism and then maybe change some of
their lines to working on on native
triples if they need to get some
improvement in performance
you know memory handling or the side
like that and so and we certainly do
that to this these associative arrays
are actually very easy to implement and
the whole d4m library it's probably a
little larger now but when I wrote this
is about two thousand lines which is
very easy to do in programming
environments that have first-class
support for to dementia
arrays operator overloading we're
overloading operators like crazy here
the plus the minus the and parentheses
all that kind of stuff and also have
first-class support for sparse linear
algebra internal under the covers we're
using sparse linear algebra like crazy
to make all this work of the language is
on earth that have those features MATLAB
is by far the most popular one which is
why we have chosen that language to
implement these features there are other
languages that have these features and
you can implement that but there are
other languages that the the don't and
if you want to implement the affirm of
those languages you certainly can you
just have to write more code so this is
sort of the language in which it can be
done in the minimum amount of code and
again we find that you know for complex
analytics that people typically can get
their work done with 50 times less code
than the equivalent Java and SQL and
this naturally leads to high-performance
parallel implementations because these
are all arrays and matrices and we have
a very well-established literature in
the community about how to do parallel
linear algebra how to do make matrices
work in parallel to very well-studied
discipline and we have a lot of
technology just to remind people how we
actually store the data in our databases
and how the data will often come out in
our associative arrays we use this
exploded schema so if we had data that
looked like a standard table here with
some kind of key and you know three
columns here with different values
associated with every one of them if we
were to insert these into a standard say
SQL type table we would just simply
create a table like this in SQL but if
we wanted to look up anything quickly we
would have to create ancillary tables
that would store indices to allow us to
do things very quickly and if we wanted
to add a totally new type of data we
would have to rethink our our schema so
what we typically do is we create this
exploded scheme
because our triple stores are very
comfortable storing you know dynamically
storing very large numbers of columns so
we essentially typically take the the
type and append the value so we create a
series of triples here usually with some
minimal information for the actual
stored value something we would never
want to look up again by itself this
doesn't give you much because most of
these triple stores are are have an
orientation typically row oriented so
you can get any row quickly with
relatively little effort and and so but
what if we also store the transpose of
that we now create a table pair such
that we can look up any row or column
very quickly and so essentially we've
indexed all the data and and you can now
do things very very quickly so that's a
very powerful powerful concept and we
exploit it all the time and of course
this whole concept looks very much like
an associative array mathematically we
can treat it as an associative array
all right so that's sort of the easy
part I think we've covered a lot of this
before in the previous lectures now
we're gonna get into some of the more
mathematical elements which aren't
necessarily hard you know they just you
know
impose notation that that that that we
don't necessarily use in our regular
day-to-day work lives so we're going to
talk about whether the values of
associations keys functions and getting
to things like matrix multiply alrighty
so mathematically we treat an
associative array as sets of keys and
values that are drawn from infinite
strict totally ordered set we'll call it
s you know like what is that what is an
infinite strict totally order set it's
just a set where there's an ordering
we're basically any two elements in the
set there's a function that will tell
you you know one is greater than the
other and they also have an equal
operation too so will tell you that you
know they give it any two values I can
ask the question is is one greater than
the other or are they equal so that's
the strict part so so that encompasses a
lot obviously it encompasses the usual
things like real numbers and integer
things like that but it also encompasses
strings
if we impose an ordering on them and we
will choose lexographic ordering almost
always to be our order in fact in the
implementation and we sort of impose
that we always use lexographic ordering
we don't really have another ordering
that is readily at our disposal so given
those keys and values an associative
array is a partial function from a set a
d-dimensional set of keys to a value so
if we have the vector of keys so
typically D will be two and you know
this the first K 1 will be the row key
and then a column key and it will map
out its partial function
from the D keys to one value so it will
look like this an associative array with
a pair of with a key a vector of keys
typically two I will have a value VI and
that it is empty otherwise so this is
its function because we only define it
where these keys exists so you can
imagine at every single associative
array is a function over the entire
space of all possible keys but we're
only giving you the ones that are
defined and everywhere else it's
undefined okay this is actually a fairly
large break from linear algebra where we
can have functions that are really a
matrix is really a function of the
indices the IJ indices which are
integers here we're all going to be
anything and we formally support the
concept of a completely empty row or
column so associative arrays don't allow
that they only give you the information
on empty information and in our
implementation we tend to store 0 as you
call them to null in this space because
the underlying sparse matrix
implementation does that 0 is
essentially treated as the null
character so so that's a big difference
is that now we can still use our linear
algebraic intuition but but that's the
fundamental fundamental difference here
so binary operations on any two
associative arrays so I have associated
for a1 and a2 with this binary operation
ok are defined essentially by two
functions the sort of upper function
here which says how we're going to treat
the keys so if we have two associative
arrays there are keys some of them can
overlap some of them cannot overlap and
our function will either choose to look
for the
Union or the intersection of those so
for instance if we do addition that's
most associated with unioning the to the
underlying keys if we do other
operations like and that's most
consistent with intersecting the two
sets of keys so obviously if it's Union
like the result will always be non-empty
if the if the function is intersection
like then there's a possibility you can
do a binary operation and the result
will be an empty associative right so we
have that sort of choice there okay and
we check we choose Union and
intersection because they're the ones
that are we could do other functions but
they're the ones that are formally
covered in set theory and and and keep
us from having to relax this very
general condition here we have we can
have equality so we can check for for
intersection and so so we're okay there
in the instance of where you so we have
an associative array okay a one with a
set of Tec your ki and a value B one
another associative array with an
intersecting ki with v2 then a three ki
will be given by this function okay it's
either going to be V you know the keys
overlap so in the if K if K I are the
same
they'll overlap and so there you go and
likewise with this you have this choice
of it could either be a union inner
intersection and then what we do with
the values like we now have a collision
is what we'll call these two keys from
two associates that are the row keys and
column keys are there same well now we
want to do something we call this we
apply this function f which we call the
collision function okay and that will
determine what the actual result is what
the new value at a3 will be
if one of these was an intersect was was
empty then obviously the union of this
we don't even have to worry about it
right that's part of the kind of the way
we approach it this if if if your there
is no collision so that means you're
applying your function with this then F
is never called so we always just do
that or that so if it's a union function
then you just get V if it's an
intersection function then you would
just get the empty set and the
underlying function never is called and
you might like well why would I care
about that well later on I'm gonna get
to do with deal with things like what is
the zero in this math or what is one in
this math and this will allow me to sort
of address some of those cases by saying
look we can kind of if there's no in it
no no no key intersection we can do that
so the high level usage of associative
rage is essentially dictated by this
mathematics and again part of the reason
we chose this very general definition is
that by definition numbers reals and
integers are all included here we have
not done we've not throwing them out and
we've also included strings I should say
at any time we can say look our values
are just real numbers and then we
essentially get the full power of linear
algebra but that's true of this sort of
card that we always try and play last
okay we try and keep our mathematics as
broad as we can and if there's
particular instances like oh well I need
the values to be real numbers or complex
numbers your integers or whatever we can
always say all right the values are that
and now we get a whole bunch of
additional properties but we sort of try
and build up the mathematics in this
general way first and then sort of play
that later yes
so I believe that actually spreadsheets
stored things as r1 r2 r3 internally and
c1 that they actually use an intra
internal triples representation and then
project that into this integer space so
so you know what what what the actual
spreadsheet does I think kind of depends
on the specific spreadsheet so just just
so the question was so they can't really
hear you on this mic was is is this more
than you need to do a spreadsheet could
you just not have just get away with
just integer in indexing and I would say
perhaps I don't really know and I and as
I said I think internally they actually
do something that's more akin to this
then then certainly when you do math and
Microsoft Excel you it's it has letters
there you give it you know a 1 B 1 those
types of things
yeah yeah one could view it that way but
people like it so we do what people like
right
it doesn't do that it obviously it does
compressor yes yeah so so mathematically
it may be more than what is minimally
required to do spreadsheet we will
discover though it is very useful and in
a certain sense allows you to do things
with spreadsheets that are hard to do in
the existing technologies which is why I
use it there's operations that I can do
with this that are very natural and the
spreadsheet data is there and I would
like to be able to do it yes so on the
keys it will be Union all right where
the value is an intersection with an
empty set we don't care what the actual
numerical thing is we'll just return the
other thing where there is a collision
and so now you have to resolve and
that's kind of why we get a lot of
mileage here because most of time we
have very few collisions and so the
something we have to worry about huge
things so we where there are collisions
if the values are numbers then we'll
just do the normal addition if the
values are strings okay then it's
somewhat undefined what we mean there
okay and I forget if d4m throws an error
in that situation if the values were
strings it might default to just doing
something like taking the max or the min
and saying you tried to add two things
for which the formal addition you know
collision function doesn't really make
sense and I'm just gonna put something
in there we can test that out you know
at the end of the class
yes it has to be a function of the type
of the value because if I'm gonna add a
real number with a string what do I do
you know because I can do that yes
another question
oh there are so many functions where you
can think well I kind of like to have it
mean this in this context so the
question was the bigger level question
was sometimes you maybe would like plus
to mean some of the other conceptual
ways that we would mean it okay so in
fact we see that a lot there's a lot of
things okay now in fact we'll get into
that space and there's hundreds
thousands millions of potential possible
algebra that you could possibly want so
what we have done is we think about the
function and we think about it in this
mathematical context and we see what
it's mathematical implications are in
terms of is it consistent with the
overall group theory of the mathematics
in which case we know that if someone
uses it that the intuition will carry
through or is it kind of forking them
off into some it's something you might
want to do but it really the result is
now taking you into a sort of a an
undefined space so that's kind of a
thing we we we use for doing that we
don't have the formal support in this of
a multiply operation that allows you to
pass in you know an arbitrary function
for doing that I should say there are
various tricks that allow you to do that
just a couple lines or two you know I
mean basically what you can do is if you
get start was like give me the
intersection of the union's first now I
know I have only in the collisions now
give me the values apply whatever
operator you want stuff the values back
in and you're done and so you can kind
of work your way through that and by
doing that your work your serve kind of
we you're doing it in ways such that you
know yeah you're outside of an algebra
here you're just kind of doing what
you're doing at it so encourage people
to do that but I'm just telling in terms
of how we choose what functions we pull
and formally support there's and there's
a few that I've been wrestling with for
a long time you know for a very long
time and and and just you know haven't
been able to decide what to do maybe I
should just pick a distant ya know if it
was in addition it was so was it so you
mean but they have the same column or
something like these are vectors these
are the row vectors so so basically we
have a one column vector with three
another column with one when we add them
together you would get a three because
it would be Union with Union the keys
and then the only addition operation
would be performed on the collision we
did an or on an and operation then the
result would just be one a vector
associated with one element in it so it
depends on the operation so Plus
formally is closer to set addition and
so therefore is a union operation and is
formally closer to set intersection and
so it's an intersection operation there
regardless in both cases the collision
function is only applied where there is
a collision yes
well so Union so the keys are a part of
a set and so they get the Union and
intersection properties of strict
totally or order so which is simple just
which is the intuitive use of Union so
so the only so the so they get so they
had they they get we'll get into that a
little bit later but they they
essentially have the binary operations
of a strict totally ordered set which is
equality and less than those yes yes
well there's a few more there's another
forty some slides so so but actually
you've gotten a lot of the good question
here so so the thing though to recognize
is that there's a lot of choices here
and the algebra you are in is determined
by the function that you choose and that
we actually you'll find yourself
switching between different algebras
fairly frequently that's how we use
spreadsheets sometimes we do this
operation and now we're in this algebra
and we do this operation and now we're
in this algebra and so that's the big
thing to kind of get it get away there
so let's get into this a little bit more
deal that's sort of the big overall so I
think we've talked about this we the the
let s as an influence trick totally
ordered set total order is an
implementation not a theoretical
requirement so so the fact that we were
imposing this infinite strict that
they're totally ordered that we don't
just allow equality is more of an
implantation detail it is very useful
for me to internally store things in
order so I can look things up quickly
however mathematically strictly if we
just had a test of equality we probably
all the math hangs together they're all
values and keys are drawn from the set
and the liable operations on them of you
know two values or keys is you know less
than equal to or greater than so those
are
three functions that we essentially
allow strict Oh totally order said only
is is to but which is less than and less
than or equal to but you get essentially
the third one for free in addition we
have the concept of three special
symbols here which we've talked about
which is the null the empty set a least
element in the set and a maximal element
to the set so be less than or equal to
plus infinity is always true and plus
infinity is we're saying it is an
element of the the maximal element is a
part of the set greater than equal to
infinity as negative infinity is always
true and the empty set is the like and
all set theory the empty set is a formal
member of of all sets so now we'll talk
about it did that sort of get to your
question about about the operations that
are defined on the keys right right so
then we talked about the collision
functions and there serves to sort of
contextual functions here Union
intersection because of those the two
operations that make sense and then
three conditions less than equal to or
greater than that is in order to
preserve this strict totally order set
once I go to values that are reals or
integers I have more operations but if
I'm just limiting myself to values that
are members of at restrict totally
ordered set this is all I have so that
means that you have sort of D plus five
possible outcomes to any collision
function that is you could have the
collision function actually choose to
put out the value of its of its
underlying key it could produce a v1 or
v2 or empty or minus infinity or plus or
sets of these so that's a fairly finite
choice of results if we're gonna stay in
this sort of restricted thing we have a
very limited number of things that can
actually happen when you're actually
applying a collision function on a
particular you know where there's an
intersection you have a fairly finite
number of
of things however the total number of
combinations of these functions gives a
very large number you know and their
function pairs gives us a very large
number of possible algebras
I did it back of all the calculations
said it was 10 to the 30th it might be
even more that in fact it might be
formally infinite for all I know so but
that was an easy calculation there's a
lot of possible algebras and and this is
a fairly impressive level of
functionality given our really
relatively small numbers of assumptions
that we have here but we are gonna focus
here on just the nice collision
functions the ones that seem to feel
like they give us intuitively useful
things so we are not going to use keys
as outputs to our function here okay we
will in some contests but in for this is
it is the so the results are and we're
gonna say the results are always single
valued we're not gonna deal with with
results expand our set our values to be
sets of values but although in certain
contexts we will do that but
mathematically let's restrict ourselves
for that we're gonna no tests on special
symbols and we're just going to
basically say our collision function can
be essentially you know if we have V
less than V 2 the answers can be one of
these five it's equal to these it can be
one of these four if it's greater than
these it can be one of these five so
that gives a fairly limited number of
possible collision functions and all
these properties are consistent with
strict totally ordered set and generally
when we handle a value of this it's
handled by the Union intersection
function first it never actually gets
passed through to this to this function
all right so it's here and just as I
said well what about concatenation in
fact there are contexts where we will
want the results to be we want to
concatenate a couple of strings together
or something like that and you know
that's fairly supported I think you know
the results can be the sets themselves
you would have a new special symbol a
symbol which is the set itself you have
now different Collision functions so you
have Union and then that one of Union
values or intersect and then Union
values and Union and intersection so
those are your functions there and
there's actually a few instances I think
we've already showed one of them in one
of the examples where we actually do
this so I just sort of throwing that in
there the concatenation is a concept
that we do think about I don't think
we've developed the formalism is richly
in situation where the values are simply
single single values but it's certainly
we certainly can and do do that yes this
one here
yeah I could have I have I might have a
typo here I should double-check that so
yeah so V Union that alright so that
should be intersection and that should
be Union and that should be intersection
and that should be Union so I just got
them to flop there so thank you
full marks to you you'll make that
change
all right that one is intersection
correct and this this three should be
intersection all right very good we'll
check in the SVN in the next town time
it will be part of your just all right
so one of the things we're eventually
gonna work towards is trying to make
matrix-multiply work in this context
okay we've already talked about the
duality between the fundamental
operation of grass which is
breadth-first search and vector matrix
multiply we continue want to want to be
able to use that it's a very powerful
feature and what we find is that in
graph algorithms where we're dealing
with things on strings or other types of
operations that most graph algorithms
can be reduced to operations what are
called on semi rings so those are
generalizations of normal linear algebra
whereby your two core operations here
the what is called the element wise
multiply in the element addition
operation our this has the property
being associative and distribute over
the plus operation and plus has the
property of being associated in
communitive examples of this include the
traditional matrix multiply plus and
multiply min dot plus or or or max dot
plus in fact there's a whole sub branch
of algebra called Max Plus algebras
which which do this another one is or
dot and and other types of things so
mathematically you know semi rings are
certainly well studied more in the
context of specific algebras like mndot
plug min plus or max plus or something
like that here's kind of with the
associative arrays we're dealing with
while you know you could be hoppin and
poppin back and forth between you know
within the same expression you could be
moving back and forth between these
different algebras so I think that's a
little bit different we're taking sort
of a bigger view a more data centric
view our data can be of different kinds
and then impose upon at different
algebras as we move forward and the real
theory questions that we're trying to
answer here is we have this concept of
associative arrays which is kind of new
we have the traditional of linear
algebra and there's going to be areas
where they overlap there are the ideas
your intuition from linear algebra and
your intuition from associative arrays
will be very very well connected okay
and there's gonna be places where
associative arrays give you new
properties that you didn't have in
linear algebra those will allow you to
new do new things and there's gonna be
cases where your linear algebra
intuition is wrong that is taking your
linear algebra intuition and applying it
to associative arrays will will lead you
into things that are that won't make
sense and so this is kind of what we're
trying to sort of give people a sense
here where you know where they overlap
where you should watch out and where
there's new properties that you know
about that you should maybe take
advantage of the the biggest one being
the universal conformance of addition
and multiplication of all associative
arrays so any two associative arrays
regardless of their size can be
multiplied and added to each other
unlike traditional linear algebra where
you have very strict constraints about
the dimensions of matrices in order for
them to be added and we do that use this
all the time we use this all the time
essentially almost exactly in the
example that we talked it was a question
that was brought up earlier we can add a
vector of three elements and a vector of
five elements and and have something
that makes sense okay like ways we can
multiply a 10 by 12 with a 6 by 14 and
have something that actually makes sense
so that's a very powerful concept and
I'd say it's used when the most commonly
used features all right so we've done
the basic definition now we're going to
sort of kind of
a little bit quicker here into the group
theory so the group theory is when we
you pick various functions what kind of
algebra is result of that so we're gonna
talk about binary operators and then get
into commutator monoids
semi rings and then something we call
the felled so our joke there is that so
a field is what when you do the
traditional mathematics of linear
algebra you're doing them over the real
field or the complex field of numbers
it's a set of numbers with certain
defined properties okay
when we impose this condition that we
are doing with strict totally ordered
sets we don't have an additive inverse
there's no way to formally subtract two
words from each other we can't have a
string and a negative string so we don't
get like a and minus a which is part of
a field so we have a Feld which is a
field without an inverse so
mathematicians are very funny and not
when they do this they often will drop
the eye or something like that you know
to make that concept so we will be doing
math over if we can have much of the
problem properties of linear algebra we
just have to recognize that we don't
have additive inverse so it's sort of
like vector spaces over selves
sometimes they're called semi vector
spaces you can put Sammy in front of
anything and it's like it's a little bit
of this but minus something so so this
is kind of our operator roadmap so you
see here we began with three definitions
we've narrow we will have narrowed it
down to 200 operators of interest of
those kind of nice collision functions
and union functions there's about 200
combinations that work well we will find
that eighteen of those operators are
associative so not associative in terms
of associative array but associative in
terms of the normal formal mathematics
of associativity we will find it and so
those font those form what are called
semi groups fourteen of them are
commutative which means they are a
billion semi groups
com utility is not really something that
is like
you know it just means that you can
switch the order of operations you know
a plus B is the same as B plus a I'm not
something that you kind of is a strict
requirement but gosh it's so nice to
have to not have to be like oh no I
switched the order and now the answer is
different so traditional matrix multiply
is like that right it's like you switch
you know eight times B is not the same
thing as B times a and so in we and we
will have that as well but commutator D
is really nice we didn't take these
fourteen operations and explore all
their possible pairs or 196 of them we
look at which one of them is distribute
there's 74 that distributes so they form
semi rings we then look to see if we
have an identity and an Annihilator
do we have some special store some of
our special symbols can they perform
that role in which case they can form a
felled and then we can create
essentially vector semi spaces or vector
spaces over these Feld's and we'll have
about eighteen of them when we're all
done and the good thing is when you get
all done with this all the ones that you
like are still in the game you know and
few of them ones you might like you know
some of my favorites you know they don't
get far down this this path as you want
but then you have these properties
you're like okay I have vector space
properties and other types of things and
I'm sure some of you will find issues or
comments or criticisms we haven't
written this up formally in journals
I've been desperately trying to hire
abstract algebra assists at summer
students and and have not been
successful so far so if you know any
abstract algebra sis that would like to
work on this we would be happy to pay
them to help us work on this if we
extend our definition of values to
include sets ie to include concatenation
this is essentially what it does you
know adds four functions here they
actually make it through all these
operations here and they basically keep
on going but then they fall away here
when we try and get to this final felled
step so but you know this is still a
very useful space to be in alright so
let me explain a little bit of how we
how we sort of navigate this space
so if we limit ourselves to special sort
of function combinations that are
associative and commutative so just
remember associative just means you can
group your parentheses however you want
I always have to look it up never once
been like associative I mean I just I
don't know this does this never been
intuitive to me but that's the grouping
of parentheses calm you tivity just
means that you can flip you so these are
our functions so these are all the 18
here and then the grade ones great out
of the ones you lose because of the come
utilities so basically this function
which is just left which just says
return the left value you know in all
circumstances well obviously that's not
commutative and the right value and
quite frankly left and right are sort of
silly functions right you should just
kind of you know sometimes almost
essentially a no op if you knew you
wanted the left value just take the left
value and move on so so so that doesn't
really so then we're left with though a
lot of the ones were like essentially
Union max so basically take the max
value Union min I call this the
intersection Delta function just return
it only gives you an answer if the
values are the same this is essentially
the Union it's sort of like the XOR
function if there's a collision blow it
away and then it's a very sort of other
kind of more unusual combinations here
dealing with the special functions how
we tend to kind of really live mostly
here these tends to be the ones that
really are the ones you use a lot I
haven't really used these too much all
right and so we're left with these a
billion what are called a billion
semigroups or these fourteen highlighted
one here so billion is a semigroup that
is commutative that's all it means
so basically it means you have
associativity
and then it's a billion if you add
commutativity to it so any sets of No
that of a grouping operations and our
commutative is a billion I mean I think
a bell did a lot more that he didn't
need to get his name associated with
that you know it could have just been
called a con sometime just called the
commutator semi group you know so you
know it's lucky when you get your name
added to some really trivial operation I
mean he did a lot of things so but they
threw him on here and in fact in group
theory they complain about this and
there are numerous rants about how
they've named all their groups after
people and they don't tell you anything
you know as opposed to other branches of
them mathematics would simply just call
this a commutator semi group so or just
a commutator of associative group you
know that might be even more more more
MORE
and of all the different properties if
most of them you can combine in whatever
way you want there's almost need a
different infinite number of groups so
there's certain ones that are most
useful I'd see here so now we start a
group and a semi group um I want to say
oh it's an abelian group without
inverses so semi group there so these
are all a billion semi group or a
billion groups without in verses or
commutator of associative groups without
inverses you know so you know you get
you see the problem you know and so I
guess he studied them a lot so he got
his name associated with them and proved
their properties and so so we have 14 of
those that form 196 pairs so these will
begin to so we want to look at the ones
that are distributive so that basically
means we have our multiply we assign one
of those operators to be the addition
operation the other to be the
multiplication operation and we need to
show that it it is distributive and of
those 196 74 operator pairs are
distributive these are called semi rings
or they could be called rings so a semi
ring is a ring without an inverse so
rings without inner versus and without
identity elements and if you look at the
various definitions I mean there
the Wikipedia definition which
mathematicians will say is that's not
really a true definition there's the
wolfram mathworld definition which is
more rigorous in the end they often
disagree on this stuff I tend to be like
you know if Wikipedia says it's true
then most people in the planet earth
believe that that is what is true and so
therefore you should be aware that that
is the truth that most people will
believe so so I I don't know which one
we've chosen here whether it's the
Wikipedia or the Wolfram there's also
various encyclopedias that define this
stuff too yes if I what ring well a ring
would be this and it would have inverses
and identity elements so it's basically
something that satisfies that's
distributive all right and has inverses
and identity elements but if you type
ring in yo the wiki you know the wiki
and I should say it's the great thing
about Wikipedia is like all the
definitions are length so you just like
by after seven or eight clicks that kind
of all holds together so it's it's it's
pretty nice and Wolfram is the same way
you can kind of if you want to just just
enough knowledge to be dangerous then
they really you know the internet that's
the Internet to your friend right so um
so moving on here and this is something
that's less important but you know kind
of for completeness if we're gonna head
towards vector space we need to address
which is the concept of identity
elements so the additive identity so
zero is the additive identity if you add
it in a normal when you think of normal
math you add zero to something it
doesn't change it all right and the
choice is for additive identity elements
could be we have three special symbols
and we could pick them we have the
multiplicative identity which is one and
the multiplicative
so of the choices here we have twelve
semi rings to the appropriate zero you
know these zeros and
we have four that actually have two
combinations and we have 16 total
operations of the six no six six
operators these are different operators
and then we call these spells without
inversions I'll get into a little bit
more so for instance we and we can skip
that for now so just a better way to
look at that is these are our operator
pairs okay and we wanted to see which
one of them sort of form these these
these belts so the ones that distribute
our mark with the D here the ones that
distribute and have a zero one operator
pair that works are shown in the square
here and some of them have two so if i
pair make plus Union men and multiply a
intersection men and I define zero to be
the empty value and plus 2b I mean one
to be plus infinity then I can create a
felled essentially out of that I had a
lot of debate with someone about this
one whether I can have plus infinity be
the zero element and have it be less
than the one element you know was a
requirement that zero actually be less
than one was sort of in in this
definition so I think it's kind of like
when I talk to math and she's like yeah
that's kind of what you want you know
then you make it that so so there's you
sure it's the full space of things that
are possible if we go back to our
concatenation operators here so these
were our for concatenation operators and
our our functions or collision functions
and this shows you what that set looks
like so these are the four by four pairs
here all operators you know they all
distributes and six to the sixteen of
these forms semi rings because you're
able to construct these various euros
and this isn't like rigorous you know I
mean someone could I probably I might
have messed one up or QED up here or
there or something like that but this
just kind of gives you a sense
the space that we're working on probably
probably so let's get into now we're
going to kind of really move it forward
here so we get into vector spaces so we
can have associate vector addition again
also see arrays or conformance we have
the concept of scalar multiplication
which is essentially applied to all
values so one of the things I really
struggle with so scalar multiplication
kind of makes sense right if I have an
associative array and I multiply it by a
scalar I can imagine just applying that
to the you know in an intersection sense
only to the to the key you know the keys
that are defined by one scalar addition
though is very difficult the scalar
addition only apply to if I have a
scalar plus an Associated ridges only
apply to the keys or is a scalar really
the associative rate is defined
everywhere over all things so it's
infinite so that's something I struggle
with so when you ask why is scalar
addition not supported indeed for M it's
because like I don't know what it's
supposed to mean you know and and you
can easily just pop out the values add
whatever you want stuff them back in and
be on your way and then you're safe so
the vector space that we form it you
know it meets the plus requirements it
commutes associative we have an identity
but we have no inverse so we have to be
careful that's why we don't have that
and a vector space it means the scalar
requirements so all associative array
operator pairs that yield Feld's also
results in vector spaces without inverse
fate versus maybe we call these vector
semi spaces I don't know when or vector
space is over a field or something like
that what kind of properties here well
we have scale identities that's great
you can create subspaces that make sense
to the concept of a span yes you can
definitely new concepts of spans does
span equal a subspace so this is a big
question in vectors space theory your
spans that have you know in subspaces
is there's not sure linear dependence is
a you know is there a non trivial linear
combination of vectors equal to the plus
identity you really can't do this
without an additive inverse and so that
becomes a little bit so we really kind
of need to redefine linear independence
which we can do but there's a lot of the
proofs of linear independence and
dependence to rely on the existence of
inverses and you probably could you know
circle your way around that so one of
the things is consider a unique a linear
combination of two associative array
vectors under what conditions do they
create a unique result so this really
depends on what you choose so for
instance if we have a cop if we have a
vector you know a 1 and a 2 when we
multiply it by coefficients a 1 and a 2
and we use these as our plus and are
multiplied and this is our zero on one
you know where our a 1 uniquely
determines you know and so for instance
if I pick in this case our canonical
identity vectors which is a 1 is equal
to infinity and minus infinity here then
we find that we can you know cover the
space very nicely if we do it the other
we can't a better way to view that is in
the drawing here so here's my whole
space of coefficients a 1 and a 2 and we
see that a 1 and a 2 uniquely define and
result with these basis vectors and a 1
and a 2 are completely degenerate with
these basis vectors so depending on the
kinds of basis vectors you have you can
create unique stuff or not unique stuff
you give yourselves actual values here
you know basically if a 1 is just equal
to this value and a 2 is equal to this
value this shows you what that look
place there's places where it's unique
there's places where they're the same
and there's places where one of them is
unique but the other is not unique so
again there's a ver
rich possible you can construct you know
using associative raises basis vectors a
very rich set of things and the same
thing goes with multi valued vectors
again different types of spaces here we
really need to kind of work this out
anybody's interested we're very
interesting having people help us work
this stuff out ah even going you know
which of these operations make sense
transpose makes total sense transposing
of associative arrays makes total sense
and it's a very efficient operation by
the way in D for M you can do transpose
is very efficiently it works out very
nicely special matrices sub matrices 0
matrices square matrices diagonal
matrices yes although diagonal matrices
are a little bit tricky upper lower
triangular yes you can kind of do this
skew symmetric no permission not really
Elementary and row column a sort of row
column equivalents sort of under certain
conditions
so there's cases these are all things
you can do in linear algebra and
sometimes you can do them with associate
arrays and sometimes you can't you have
to think about them matrix multiply is
sort of our crown jewel always
conformant can multiply any sizes
whenever you want there's two ways to
think about this you can make your head
hurt a little bit when you start dealing
with the null elements and like when
does the Union operator get applied and
when does the so when you do computation
there's two ways to formulate a matrix
multiply there's the inner product
formulation which is typically what
people use when they actually program it
up because it tends to be more efficient
that's basically you take each row in
each column you do an inner product and
then do the results okay
mathematically from a theory perspective
it you get yourself in less trouble if
you think in terms of the outer product
formulation which is basically you take
each row and vector you do their outer
product to form a matrix and then you
take all of these and then combining
them all together
okay with with the operation and that
that theoretically that will actually
keeps you staying here and that's the
way to think about it mathematically a
variety of matrix multiplies examples I
won't go into them here obviously depend
heavily on what our collision function
you know G is here gives you different
values and different behaviors the
identity element may be a left identity
right identity in some senses we if it
seems to be okay but it's there's not
really the I need any available is a
little bit tricky inverses boys it hard
to construct inverses when you don't
have underlying inverses it's just
really tricky and so probably are not
gonna get anything looks like an inverse
you can do i ghen vectors in certain
restrictive cases sort of and there are
actually papers written about this but
it's only on very then the row and
column keys need to be the same and
stuff and so you know one thing I really
would like to explore is the pseudo
inverse so pseudo inverse a plus
satisfies these properties and I
actually think that we are probably be
pretty good shape for pseudo inverse and
the pseudo inverse is what you need to
solve the least squares problem and I
think solving the least squares problem
is actually something we might really be
interested in doing in some other
problems so I do need to work this out
if people would like to explore this
with me we have a whole set of theorems
that we'd like to prove spanning
theorems linear independence identities
inverses determinants pseudo inverses
eigenvectors convolutions all these for
which of these you know do these apply a
lot of good math that could be done here
call to arms for those of people who are
interested in this type of thing and so
just to summarize you know the algebra
so see arrays provides it's kind of this
mathematical foundation I think I've
tried to show you the core parts that
are really well solid and expand that to
the points or you can see where it is
well we don't really know exactly what
should be happening here and give you a
little bit of logic you know behind how
we do this
a small
assumption really yields usually a rich
mathematical environment and so I have a
short code example which is really just
it's not really teaching anything no no
it's just to show you that I tested all
these properties using d4m which was
nice and really in a very kind of a
spreadsheet kind of style and so I'm
just going to show you that there's
really just one example takes a few
seconds to run but but and then the
assignments so these are in this in this
in this part in the directory oh I can
and then the assignment should you show
do it is now sir if you didn't do the
last assignment well you're gonna need
to do that to now do this assignment so
basically for those of you who did the
last assignment bit of array of a
drawing and looking at the edges and
stuff like that I want you to think
about that associative array and think
about which kind of these operations
would make sense if you were to try and
add them or multiply them or whatever
just explore that a little bit and just
write up you know okay I think these
kind of operations would make sense here
you know addition would make sense if
it's Union and the collision function is
is this or something like that you know
you'll have to think about what your
values are could just be your values or
just one you know something like that
you might be like oh my values are zero
one and I want one plus one to equal
zero so you might add on an or XOR
operation or something like that so so
just sort of think about what your
example was and think about these ideas
a little bit and just write a few
sentences on kind of what that means the
last side here is just you don't really
get this question but if you want to
compare kind of what the difference
between associative arrays are and the
algebra defined by Cod that serve as the
basis of SQL this is just a little table
that serve describe some of the
different system